Congratulations, we're at the end of lesson four.
[SOUND] Wow. That was a lot of stuff
we covered. Well, lesson four is also the
most content-heavy lesson in this course, so we're
really happy to see you here. We covered
data relationships, specifically the ancestor and that has
a relationship. We also looked at queries, query
by kind and then filtered by ancestor and
then filtered by different properties. Datastore indexes,
we took an in depth tour of datastore
indexes, it allows you to do queries in datastore and we've wrapped it up with
different consistency modelsa and transactions in datastore.
In the next lesson, we will look at
heavy duty stuff. You want to know what heavy duty is? Well, be here to join us.